my comedian michelle wolf the
entertainer at the last year's White
House Correspondents that are attacking
the White House Correspondents
Association for ditching the traditional
comedian and booking historian Ron
chernow as next year's featured speaker
wolf tweeted quote the WHCA are cowards
the media is complicit and I couldn't be
prouder also tonight following Brian
Kemp successful gubernatorial campaign
in Georgia against Democratic challenger
Stacey Abrams well several Hollywood
actors are now calling for a boycott of
Georgia's film and television industry
with reaction author of the brand-new
book American entrepreneur how 400 years
of risk takers innovators and business
visionaries built the u.s. a duck and
buck commander CEO the man himself
Willie Robertson get a little grayer
there that beard mr. Robertson
give them all now no come on no nothing
that you're getting greyer by the day I
can't believe I will old you look well
you're not you're gonna look a little
more silver as well my friend and Dan
bonds you know former Secret Service
officers Spygate his new best-selling
book you know you're our rarity Willie
you guys I have this hit show that goes
on for years and years and years you
actually mentioned God in a positive way
the family prays at the end of every
episode even with your crazy uncle and
your dad who wanted to baptize me in an
alligator pool he still does what still
sighs I'm not doing it in an alligator
swamp
he wants to take me out of there
alligators I've seen episode whether the
alligators live he wanted to take me out
there and dunk me he still does well you
know our family is strong about our
faith we were we were willing to show
that and and never held back from that
and you know I think all this this
boycott boycott this boycott that it's
it's getting a little old in my opinion
and I think you know we've got to deal
with the results and say let's move on
and be positive and I mean if not we're
gonna have to where we'll have to have
all new entertainment for you know the
left side and the right side for each
other comedians are supposed to be fun
so be funny and be funding for all of us
but you know I think a lot of it will
watch a lot of sore-loser ISM damn
Bungie no I mean Bill Clinton 52 House
seats he lost in his first midterm eight
Senate seats you know then you got real
winner lost loses six Senate seats 63
House seats and that's Barack Obama's
first midterm Trump picks up the all
these Senate seats and nearly lost 37
House seats which by the way is
historically always happen and they
can't handle the loss Trump outworked
him again yeah wherever he campaigned
for the Senate seat Sean they did really
well but you know think about how silly
and ridiculous this this entertainment
industry Fobo cot of Georgia is right
Sean so you have this entertainment
industry with large swaths azure swathes
of the more liberal right they work at a
state largely in California on the west
coast we have really high taxes the
entertainment industry escapes to go to
Georgia which is more business-friendly
which makes them more money they lose a
race by a sliver
hey listen Stacey Abrams did pretty well
for Georgia but she's still lost and
they called for a boycott of the
industry that's making the money well I
mean they live in an intellectual black
hole you think of the billions of
dollars places like Netflix Hulu Amazon
they're all investing in content it's
it's massive amounts of money and what
they're finding is family friend it
friendly good themes uplifting movies
that have a message and aren't afraid to
say they believe in God like I do and
you do they're doing well well there's
no doubt that PG movies and movies that
more people can watch are more
profitable I've been to Georgia I've
seen the new studios it's unbelievable
what they're investing down there and so
it's a it's gonna be a loss and but
these boycotts have been tried before is
you know speaking of Georgia you know
they were gonna years ago boycott
chick-fil-a we were boycotted against
and it those things failed so I think
support boycotts you know what boycotts
are they're just the way of shutting
down and silencing people you don't
agree with Dan bonds you know you know
the
as well as anybody yeah I mean the
almost the greatest thing that can
happen to your business these days is to
have some of these silly liberal groups
boycott you I mean Sean I want to go get
a chick-fil-a sandwich after the
chick-fil-a boycott well he's talking
about the live was around the corner up
in Frederick in Maryland it took me two
hours to get a sandwich I wish I had
owned the chick-fil-a when that point
which god I wish I was in more money
than Willie
we all wish we owned chick-fil-a live we
can agree on that
by the way cracker breath is another one
I mean look at Cracker Barrel no
everyone wants to go there right all
right so what's up with the Robertsons
how's everybody's doing there
everybody's doing fantastic we are ready
for Thanksgiving and that means hunting
seasons here so we're back in the woods
and still doing what we do yes we're -
what we do sit around eat a lot pray and
and chin that have a great business you
know what dan and I work too hard we
weren't smart like you right there to
say that Oh save it guys are geniuses
man all right guys good to see you both